with an offer on the table should the
rmt do you think have called off their
rail strikes today
well we were told when Rishi sunak took
over as prime minister that we were
going to have a more pragmatic Common
Sense approach to government but what is
actually happening is he's doubling down
on what his predecessors were doing
refusing to get round the table refusing
to engage properly with the trade unions
there is a deal there to be done you can
hear it in the language from all of the
trade unions that are on on strike they
want to do a deal they want compromise
but they're being locked out of
negotiating room by the government so uh
you know what we need to do is see clear
and constructive dialogue happening and
finding that middle ground and that is
the way that we're going to resolve
these strikes
you say there's a deal there to be done
there is a deal currently on offer by
Network rail to our the rmt for example
they say that would mean Rises are
between 9 and 14 more for those on Lower
salaries is it time for the rmt to
accept that offer
well the rmt operates like all trade
unions on a democratic basis and they
have to consult their members uh you
know the executive consults for
membership in order to determine whether
or not the deal is acceptable and you
know that is a process that has to go on
within the rmt the the broader Point
remains that a huge amount of time uh
and indeed money has been wasted uh by
the government's refusal to get around
the table and negotiate with the trade
unions in a constructive and grown-up
way and and we're paying the price for
that commuters are paying the price for
that um the economy is paying the price
for that and we really do need to see
now a much more common sense pragmatic
approach from the government
clearly it is for the rmt to decide
amongst their members whether they
accept the offer but I think a lot of
people want to know where labor stands
on this you put a lot of pressure on the
government to to enter talks and be
constructive as you say but people want
to know whether you think that the kind
of offers that are being put to workers
are reasonable or not are you able to
say what is a reasonable offer for some
of these Strikers
well what a contrast between the
grotesque profits that these oil and gas
companies are making and many other
companies are earned and you know CEOs
of organizations paying themselves huge
bonuses right across the economy working
people just want a fair share of uh of
so what is a fair share the economy that
we from the economy that we are that we
see and of course we're seeing an
economy that's been fundamentally
neglected by government for 13 years and
we're seeing the cost of that coming
through uh every single day so you know
the fair share is about a negotiation
it's a percentage uh increase that
actually helps to deal with the cost of
living crisis helps to deal with runaway
inflation uh that we're seeing every
everybody knows when they're going to
negotiation you don't get everything
that you want but you are also clear
what your bottom line is when we go into
government we will need to look at the
books we will inherit a terrible
terrible
after 13 years of catastrophically
shambolic government we're going to have
to fix that mess look across the books
and of course negotiate with trade
unions when negotiations are necessary
we will go into those negotiations uh
with a hard-headed approach okay that is
protecting the public finances but is
also recognizing that working people
deserve their fair share okay and it's
clear that labor doesn't don't want to
outline exactly what they think that the
a fair share should be but you mentioned
energy Giants and their profits let's
talk a little bit about shell they've
reported their highest profits in their
history yesterday 32 billion pounds now
the government has introduced a windfall
tax that was increased and extended by
the chancellor in the Autumn statement I
mean that now amounts on top of other
taxes corporation tax
Etc to about 75
labor is still calling on the government
to go further isn't it so so what would
a windfall tax under labor look like
well of course the government had to be
drag Kicking and Screaming to agree with
the windfall tax they spent months and
months and months opposing our plans and
then ended up adopting them so what we
should at least be doing is back dating
uh the windfall tax to when Labor uh
introduced the idea in the first place
uh what we also need to do is see the
loopholes being closed so the oil and
gas companies are being led off the hook
um through certain loopholes connected
to investment being offset against uh
their their tax liabilities that needs
to stop as well Labor's got a clear and
detailed plan for doing that and the
government should adopt it straight away
on the closing of that loophole as you
say it allows energy firms to reduce
their payments if they go on and invest
capital in new production we have in the
bank of England yesterday expressing
real concern about growth in the economy
they said one of the real problems was
low business investment so don't we need
to do everything to incentivize
businesses to invest their money
yeah but don't forget that these are
excess profits these are the windfalls
of War as a direct result of Putin's
barbaric invasion of Ukraine the oil and
gas companies are laughing all the way
to the bank and that cannot be allowed
to continue so we're not talking about
taxing the the basic bottom line of
these companies we're taxing the excess
profits that have been made as a direct
result of the war and there should be
one-off taxes which should only be in
place until such time as the war is
finished which we really hope will be as
soon as possible and the the energy
Market goes back to uh business as usual
so it's it's those excess profits that
need to be taxed properly it is not
right but these companies are benefiting
directly from Putin's barbaric invasion
of Ukraine these are the windfalls of
war and they need to be taxed properly